patri céastien est avec
nous merci d'être avec nous mon Patrick
il est 19h21 on est en direct et c'est
un bonheur de te voir mon chéri c'est
Gentit moment aussi je suis content de
vous voir tu es bien là tu es bien tu es
bien dans ta tte bien ici vous m'ave
fait marrerais tu es bien là moi j'adore
j'adore quand tu viens moi c'est comme
s'il y a un mec qui de la famille qui
vient ben je fais partie de la famille
un peu quand même je suis content de
voir Pascal parce qu'on avait beaucoup
discuté on a un point
commun son grand-père arrête avec
[Rires]
Pascal Pat par G j'ai grandi dans un
petit village en corise qui s'appelle
juyac et son grand-père et de juyac
voilà non c'est vrai il y a combien 100
habitants là-bas non il y a quoi 100
habitants grand déconné non plus non
malheureusement il il a 8 ce sont des
choses qui arrivent il y a 800
non c'est mais je sais qu'il aime bien
Pascal Patrick mais tout le monde aime
bien Pascal elle fait
l'unanimité vraiment c'est bon c'est pas
la peine d'applaudir pas que ça à
non plus est-ce que tu es heureux mon
chéri très heureux est-ce que j'ai l'air
il y a le seul truc qui mine c'est que
franchement c'est dans un mois j'ai 70
Pich ça me fait ch tu mais non
t'inquiète pas je vais te dire là c'est
pas dans la tête c'est pas dans le corps
c'est dans le
[Applaudissements]
slip ah ouais les gars Anouna
merci merci ça c'est Anouna Anouna 27
septembre un endroit où je sais pas les
très bien tu vois tu as peut-être les 70
cm non tout va très bien j'ai fait là
j'ai écrit ce bouquin que j'aime
beaucoup et puis j'ai j'ai fait un été
je me suis éclaté comme tu peux pas
savoir puis je suis vachement étonné
parce que dans mon public les mecs qui
viennent de me voir il y a plein de
gaminsou que je suis pas aller chercher
qui ont entre 25 an avait B qui étaent
là ils sontqués
c'est là le dernier concert comme une
folle je sais non j'ai fait des j'ai
fait des concerts tout l'été avec mon
truc çaappelle 30 ans de fiesta on a
fait sauter les gens par on a fait un
truc extraordinaire au festival de
poupée V ah ouais ils étaient 32 enfin
je crois avoir les images je sais pas si
tu les as mais pas cétait qu'on a les
images personnes W ou 32000 ils étaient
et déguisé 32000 déguisésor c'était
extraordinaire ça c'est un kiff hein
puis en a fait plein d'autres et puis on
fait ça lesété prochain t je peux fr toi
tu es parti alors moi moi j'adore ce que
je fais parce que je m'éclate ici sur C8
j'ai une liberté incroyable le public
est là je suis tellement heureux de vous
retrouver tous les soirs je vous j que
c'est vrai mais je trouve que tu es
parti au bon moment la télé à la limite
je te J je crois bien que oui non mais
franchement il se passe quoi à la télé
il se passe rien je sais pas moi c'est
dis la vérité franchement c'est c'est un
peu le thème de mon Bou la Nost la
nostalgie c'est pas la nostalgie la
nostalgie c'est tout été mieux avant
c'est la nostalvie c'est c'est peut-être
qu'on devrait prendre des valeurs des
trucs d'avant pour les les adapter
aujourd'hui pour aller mieux c'est ce
que j'entends autour de moi il s'agit
pas de refuser le progrès moi je préfère
le je préfère le GPS à la carte routière
je te rassure mais mais il y a des
valeurs d'avant avait à la télé
d'ailleurs Ron ce que tu dis vous rendez
compte qu'avant les gars il faut savoir
il y avait pas de GPS ça veut dire que
moi mon quand il m'aamené un
anniversaire frère il était commass dans
la voiture avec une carte avec une lampe
torche comass et je me rappelle
c'est au Diable Vert cette affaire d non
papa c'est au diable va
vert vous dire c'est vrai
vra c'est vrai pas je suis pas j'ai pas
un minitel et je roule pas en sonx mais
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des valeurs de
solidarité il y a des c'est c'est très
antinomique ce qui nous manque je trouve
aujourd'hui c'est un mélange de liberté
c'est ça et d'autorité ouis parce qu'il
y a des trucs bon si je parlais un petit
peu plus grave je discut avec des amis
l'autre jour moi de mon montant si je
peux me permettre comme ça on cayassait
pas les pompiers et les tbibes moi ça me
casse les couilles de voir qu'on peut
frapper des gens qui viennent t'aider te
sauver la vie je suis désolé mais on
devrait être beaucoup plus dur avec il
va le casser des cailloux va casser des
cailloux pendant 4 ans qu si je te dise
et ça ça me choque voilà c'est des
valeurs d'avant des valeurs de respect
euh on c'était pas des anges les gens
d'avant je disc avec des copains les les
appaches qu'il y avait dans les dans les
années début du siècle dernier ils était
pire que la racaille qui a aujourd'hui
dans Paris se met une terreur pas
possible c'est ça la nostalgie c'est ça
la nostalgie ton livre c'est ça il faut
le dire au téléspectateur c'est Patrick
il dit pas tout tout ce qu' aant c'est
de la merde il dit non il faut faire un
mix de c'estàdire que ce que je résume
déjà une chose il faudrait plus d'humain
moi ça me manque moi le le pompiste me
manque le mec au guichet me manque
j'appelle là j'ai appelé les TB à
Boulogne là ils me disent appelez le 115
ils vont faire une consultation en visio
fait chier une consult
envie d'avo un vrai fa j'ai envie d'AV
j'ai envie tu vois ce que je veux dire
c'est humainement il me il me manque des
alors ce que je dis dans le bouquin je
dis que si on continue comme ça on va
aller dans le mur et il y a deux
solutions quand tu vas dans le mur soit
tu t'écrases dessus soit tu freine avant
tu prends deux pas d'élan et tu passes
par-dessus et pour moi les deux pas
d'élan c'est revenir à un peu plus de
respect un peu plus de solidarité c'est
pas bisounours ça c'est pas s'envoyer
des émoticones c'est juste il y a des
respects il y a des choses que que qu'on
respectait avant et puis nos libertés
aussi hein ce qui est terrible c'est je
t'en parlais tout à l'heure tu m'as dit
ah oui c'est vrai c'est que dans mes
années à moi l'ordre moral il était de
droite tu sais c'était giscar c'était
euh tout était tabou fallait marcher en
r et maintenant l'ORD moral il est
devenu de gauche c'est qu'il y a tous
ces mecs là les les wist là qui veulent
t'interdire qui veulent t'interdire ce
qui fait plaisir et qui veulent
t'imposer ce qui fait chier exactement
et ça ça me voilà mais après je suis pas
là pour je donne pas de leçon j'analyse
simplement par rapport à ce qu'il y a
aujourd'hui et puis ce que j'ai vécu
parce que je raconte pas mal de trucs je
raconte le Paris des années 80 Paris
village
aussi je pis garer je pouis garer ma
bagnole à Barb sans la retrouver sur cal
quoi tu vois je vouis j'allais dans la
cité des 4000 voir mes
copines c'est pas c'était c'était gay
c'était plus gay plus
joyeux c'est qui les copines de la me
non il y a un truc qui s'appelleit je ça
existe encore la C 4 tu me
[Rires]
regardes tu sais en plus je regarde ta
chemise là il y avait une il y avait il
y avait des couleurs c'est pour ça que
la couverture du bouquin est en la
courur du bouquin il y a des couleurs
parce que la vie était beaucoup plus en
couleur euh à bas ils avaient des
fringues Carlos même les musiques étaai
plus les momes d'aujourd'hui que je
croise là qui ont 20 piges sur quoi tu
crois qu'il s'éclate le soir sur les
chansons des années 80 ouais c'est vrai
tu as raison sur sur ce C gu là tu vois
donc le le le bouquin c'est ça c'est
retrouvver un peu des des trucs d'avant
et si on pouvait moi dans ma vie je le
fais hein je mets tout ça je mets tous
ces ingrédients ouverture patri c'est
c'est un ben c'est la transmission tu
vois j'ai 70 piges j'ai suffisamment
ouais mais j'ai suffisamment vécu de
truc pour transmettre ce gamin là moi je
veux qu'il soit heureux comme moi je
l'ai été malgré les les coups du sort
les machetes on s'en fout ça nous on a
vach ont bien vécu parce qu'on avait et
ce petit je voudrais qu'en appliquant
ces chosesl et ben il soit heureux aussi
qui se on devrait marquer sur les
couveuses vivre-tu tu sais je le mets
dans mon bouquin parce que on se gâche
la vie on va la perdre de toute façon ou
autant en profiter un peu plus et se la
faire protéger aussi parce que les minau
d'aujourd'hui ils ont envie qu'on les
protège euh et puis d'avoir cette
liberté d'être un peu ce qu'on veut
alors il y a un moment tu t'es dit je
vais quitter la France ou pas du tout
jamais et quoi jamais mais mais
j'adore mon pays moi c'est ça c'est Ren
tu vois ils vont ils vont me traiter
encore de nationaliste j'explique dans
le bouquin je suis né après la guerre
bizarrement 8 ans après la guerre de 45
et ben dans mon village en plus j'étais
à Juillac tu connais c'est pas loin de
radour surglan et Thul où il y avait eu
des massacre incroyable il va pas nous
parler de la merre de Pascal toute la
soirée non je te dis c'était c'était à
côté pas loin d' radour sur GL t où il y
avait des massacres incrobles et les
vieux chez moi ils m'ont appris ils
m'ont dit tu sais il y a des momes de 20
ans qui sont allés se faire massacrer
pour ta liberté ouais ouais ou c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui quand je vois les
mêmes momes qui brûlent le drapeau
français j'ai envie de leur dire mes
pauvre con c'est bon ça va euh si ton
grand-père s'était pas fait trouer la p
je va dire oui je vais te dire un truc
aussi donc j'aime mon pays oui ou mais
oui mais tu vois ça c'est vraiment et
c'est ça que je vois moi c'est vraiment
une minorité c'est aussi maintenant le
gros problème c'est les réseaux voilà
les défensement parce qu'il y a des
trucs voilà qui sont bien mais c'est
c'est ces quatre abrutis qui vont euh
brûler le drapeau français pour des
milliers de jeunes qui disent moi je
sens bien dans mon pays la France je
suis heureux d'être là voilà jeunes faut
être beaucoup plus sévère C minorité là